hello and welcome to moses and friends
i'm your host moses storm or as i'm
known in the chat where's conan
how come casey neistat and king
joffrey's love child is talking at me
uh if you haven't been here before this
is the show where we take all of our
favorite people from the conan show we
put them up live we're live in the chat
if you guys have any questions for me
we have a great show tonight roy wood jr
and ron funches are here
uh first guest i'm gonna bring on
someone i spent a lot of time with
we toured he was the co-host of this
show when we did it for human beings
please welcome the very funny
flu labor flula germany's own oh
hello to you moses how are you oh you
know who knows
who knows everything who knows i feel
you look a little uncomfortable moses so
i would like to welcome you to your own
show
so let's let's begin here a little bit
okay
thank you yeah let's go here we go
okay oh wow you've made me a background
that looks like uh rain
bubbles this is very greasy rain it's
stormy
it's stormy moses okay so this is the
royalty-free background you could afford
and
a unicorn look at this look at these
guys
it's not just a normal storm moses it's
a magical storm it's for you
it's a corn storm the console and watch
out oh no watch out here comes
oh wow look at that these you know this
is the first time my
name has been pulled in in this
direction you know no one's made the
connection before
zero times zero times hasn't happened
before
oh you really went all out we have hello
hello moses stormy couple h is in there
wow thank you for being here uh actually
you wanted to come on the show which is
which is new
yeah because there's an issue that's
near and dear to your heart so a lot of
businesses are starting to slowly reopen
and the last business on the list it's
being considered non-essential
is night clubs and you spend a good
portion of your life in nightclubs from
djing
your events to hosting awake for an
ex-xfl player
once so you think that that nightclubs
actually are
an essential business not just i think i
know it moses when i go into my
nightclubs now everyone is very excited
to see me
and we have very very clear rules i will
show you now because i've come prepared
and this is what you're going in the
nightclubs
yeah i mean it's kind of okay yeah
okay yeah so this is a this is a uh just
a clip of me at
um gurkhein two days ago as you can see
um
just making sure everyone is okay this
is the club oh you're in the hood there
that's me yeah yeah i'm a hooter okay
and this is how people are entering the
club so it's not just show your id
no no this is the club this is the club
okay um testing all day that's all we do
it's just 24 testies
right but i mean don't people go to a
club to kind of unwind it's like a dark
room you kind of want to drink and dance
with anonymity this seems
it seems very i don't know clinical i
don't know if this is the the path
forward
well i can tell you what we do is moses
each person enters first they enter the
wonderful disco
and then i provide them with a very fun
adventure shall i show it to you
yes please okay here it is here we go
okay this looks look at this how many
people are in the room moses as i'm
dancing
yeah okay oh good to see you
i love this those feets are pumping so
deep and dark
i gotta say it's very unsettling to see
you laterally and
upside down and then watch moses like
when romance happens look
hey what's your favorite color it's blue
okay
okay so this is your pitch to
essentially get
our governor gavin newsom to to to open
back up
nightclubs this is this is what the the
future of nightclubs look like
it's like you know when your uncle is
like running down the street and the dog
bites his testicles
it's the lesson like run away fail is
all this time yeah yes
yes run away from doggies listen
remember your uncle
so okay so your idea is to essentially
open a nightclub that's so bad and so
safe that that oh wow that is unsettling
uh that that
they will be forced to open nightclubs
okay yes it just seems very clinical and
in hospital like moses have you been to
germany before
no i haven't that's very fair though
yeah this is very fair
this is what we call romance lighting
this is this is romantic light is
setting the mood yeah
yes every intercourse begins with this
this many halogens are required moses
oh my god i can't wait to go uh if only
we were allowed to go
yeah no one is allowed sorry it's very
difficult can you see how easy pga can
be not prevented when you're in a room
with yourself time spot
yeah so that's that's really the
argument is that if you do open
nightclubs i mean it's a super spreader
venue i mean people are bumping into
each other constantly
yes people are are yelling over loud
music
yes have you thought about addressing
that if people are yelling and maybe
spreading droplets
is there a way to to curb that in my
discord there will be at least 15
nuns and they will be measuring you
and the space between of your mouth and
other mouths and perhaps genitals
and things like this okay a couple
things come up with that
uh what nuns would agree to go into a
nightclub
too would it not kill the vibe i mean
it's a very sexually charged
vibe in there okay well uh but by the
nightclub before
okay moses well number one i think one
of us i mean out of the six of us here
one of us has not seen the film nuns on
the run
am i correct i have not seen that so add
me to one of the floating heads
there is this the whoopi goldberg movie
no that's a sister's acting sister
actually he's nanny's on the right
you're not not
nuns on the run not familiar at all oh
it's very good it is not part of the
sister acting franchise
it is just about some nuns that engage
in cardiovascular activities
and also there is a disco scene moses so
you're trying to raise
money to open this on purpose bad
night club or you're trying to get real
clubs open it's not clear what's
what the motive is but i would like to
still let's get to it very quickly sorry
moses let's transition to the most
important part it's
um my hashtag which is flaxseen what do
we got here what's this okay we have
hashtag flaxseen sorry moses it's not
vaccine
yes flag scene so it is the fuel effect
so if you donate to hashtag flag scene
this will speak to
it's a bot i've created it will send an
email to uh gavil nusso
and he will he will then begin to open
yeah he will begin to open the club is
and then also this donates to the sister
act i mean sorry the nunnies on the
runny two
franchise fundraiser so
that way we can get nuns on the run
which would be nuns on the gallop
this is the nuns on the gallop and then
that will also help to encourage people
to dance safely so one kickstarter and
you have multiple issues
going into this event and how much money
are you looking to raise
at least five to six euros
well that doesn't seem like a lot it
seems like people in the chat could
donate that
do people want to see this is this
something that needs to happen i don't
know where is the chat
it's always been inside you that sounds
highly inappropriate
um i i feel okay
oh is this we need to end this right yes
i think
uh there's no better way to end a bit
either with someone you know getting
shot or
they say playing a brass instrument okay
i will begin to just
solo and then you can cut me out at any
moment
okay okay moses is for you hashtag
flaxseed
wow what an ending the chemistry that we
have it's like two people
that have testified against each other
in court do love it
bye flula sorry i don't know how to mute
myself i'm trying to mute it
you know what it's gonna stay on in the
background for everyone and maybe um
you know just we want to hear you
breathing back there okay
okay bye-bye sorry let's see
that's everyone please donate to
not his his cause